Draymond we made it happen absolutely
you're on the show no I'm legitimately
so happy you're on the show because I
feel like I already will always send you
so many questions about basketball and
just like life in general so for us to
be able to sit and really hash it out I
am very excited to do you have seen so
much you've won so much so there's much
to discuss
um obviously I want to begin with the
Warriors I think that everybody has this
very specific idea of what a dynasty is
to them but you are part of something
that is an Undisputed Dynasty so what
does it mean to be a dynasty to you
um
well obviously you know in order to have
a dynasty you have to win but I think
you have you know when I look at
dynasties it's like you dominate over
over a period of time you know it's not
like oh we want a championship
and you know then
maybe we messed around in one another
and it's like no you dominated for a
period of time and I think when when you
look at what we've been able to
accomplish since 2015
um you know obviously there's injuries
and things involved in it but
you know you take we've dominated over
that period of time regular season you
know getting going 73-9 four
championships playing in what six NBA
finals in eight years I think to
dominate a period of time I think that's
a dynasty you can't just win one and say
or you know or get close and say we're
in Dynasty also I mean you're a dynasty
because you literally couldn't remember
the numbers you're like six and eight I
think it's just so many numbers I don't
know when did you know though that this
was a dynasty
um
you know it's funny because
you can never really put your finger on
and be like oh that's it like it's a
Dynasty now you just kind of get that
feeling like I I'd say for us
once once we won the third championships
it's like yo we're building a dynasty
but even then we weren't saying like yo
we built the dynasty it's like yo we're
building a Dynasty now I think a part of
that could be feeling like you're not
done and so in saying that we're like
we're not done so we're building a
dynasty and so maybe some people would
say we we were already at Dynasty after
three but for us we're still continuing
to build it now
and now we know but you know I think
that also speaks to this just kind of
human idea that you don't know the
gravity of a moment when you're in the
moment that's a fact you know that's a
fact like if you didn't feel after that
third one oh this is what this is
because everyone else I think kind of
felt that but you got to sit back and
say okay I know I'm a part of it but
what does being a part of this mean in
the grand scheme of things absolutely
well I think you know when you're in it
um
I'll take you back to when we won our
first championship when we won our first
championship uh I remember sitting with
I think 3D and RP Seiko Smith and could
have been Rick Fox they were outside
they had the big trailer outside of
Oracle Arena we were doing like some
media in the trailer
and they were asking me about the
feeling I said well the filling was so
amazing my biggest fear is that I'll
never have the opportunity to experience
that again
and
and and coming back to it now it's like
you're still always chasing that feeling
so once you win it once like we won it
last year it's like that's great like
that's the fourth one
but in my mind I'm saying going from
three to four championships
felt like for me like going from one to
four like that's how drastic the jump
fell from going from three to four so in
my mind I'm like well what does five
feel like I mean that got to be a
totally different feeling yeah and so I
think when you're in it you're always
just looking to chase that next thing
that next one trying not to get
satisfied with what you already have see
that's interesting because I have been
told that nothing will ever compare to
the feeling of that first one so even
when you win like two three four
whatever you're like but it isn't
hitting the same as that that hasn't
been your experience though I don't know
it's nothing like the first one yeah
because everyone since
you're looking at the guys who won it
the first time and looking at their
reaction right and like what I
appreciate most about all of these
championships since the first one is
watching guys who haven't done it and
how they're feeling how they're reacting
watching them for those next three weeks
three to four weeks and how they're
acting out in the world and how they're
moving around like watching Andrew
Wiggins body language change like
that's what you get the most joy out of
watching Gary Payton walk around and say
I got I got my first ring before my dad
got his first ring career-wise like
that's what you get the most joy out of
and so I don't I don't think like and
when I look at all four of them like
this fourth one it was special because
everybody come to the South the injuries
I mean
nobody believed in us and
and so it was special in a sense from
that space But
at the same time the filling of it it
didn't compare to number one yeah not at
all not even the filling not even close
like I think
that's obviously special right how that
feels for one but there's this element
of like
sadness isn't the right word but if you
know that that high is never going to be
as high does that make sense absolutely
I'm like well then what is the
you're you're hungry but you're never
full you're right because like you were
full that first one yeah and now
everything else is just kind of
complementary absolutely you you never
get that um
you never find the that feeling of
fulfillment through the amount of
championships right like I think you end
up finding the feeling of fulfillment
through other things and then the
Championships are like icing on the cake
like oh and by the way we've done these
like we did this this and this and this
but
it's never truly fulfilling and I think
you know
maybe it's fulfilling what you're done
and you can look back on and say oh we
did that and that fulfilled me but while
I'm playing
it's never fulfilled me yeah and it's a
very interesting thing because it
doesn't get any higher than that and yet
my number one goal is always to win it
like I want that feeling but then once
you win it don't get me wrong like I
don't take it for granted
but right after it's like oh man we
gotta go try to do this again yeah and
so it's never really fulfilling
so if you're already a champion right
what are you trying to prove each year
that there's nothing anyone can do about
it
and I think for us for myself that's
been that's that's been the goal like
you know I've
last year during the season
I'm like yo we're going to win the
championship and everybody like why do
you think that like why do you keep
saying y'all gonna win the championship
y'all was won 15 games two years ago
y'all lost in the two playing games like
why do you think y'all gonna win a
championship and I remember saying
verbatim well
it still has not been proven that when
Steph
clay and my myself are together the
whole way healthy that someone can beat
us
and so until someone can prove that
I get such a blast out of proving to
other people that there's actually
nothing y'all can do about it and you
talk all this stuff about being oh you
talk all of this stuff about they can't
do and nobody has figured it out yet
yeah that's what I think for me is like
it's kind of like you got this little
gold shiny object dangling over people's
head like hey you can't get this thing
yeah
you don't yeah you can't grab it yeah so
if if you were thinking about the four
that you've won right I want you to name
each one like what did each one
represent for you
the first one was
um disbelief like it was like
going into that year like yo we got a
chance to be good and then we start
playing we like yo I'll never forget
maybe 10 games into the season we all
looking at each other like hey
we may be well we we can win a
championship and so all of a sudden the
mindset turns like yo we can go win the
championship
the 2017 one was like
Katie's first year
you
with KD coming here you know like we
cannot lose like
we'll never hear the end of it he'll
never hear the end of it we got to
protect our brother we are not allowed
to lose and quite frankly if I'm being
honest
up until Christmas Day we hadn't had it
figured out and after that Christmas Day
game I remember Kevin like I don't know
like I'm trying to take this backseat to
step and stuff like dude don't take a
back seat to me I'll figure it out go do
what you do and then from that point on
it was just a matter of like waiting on
the date that we could win like we knew
we were winning it was just a matter of
the date getting there yeah and I think
for that one it was that one was almost
like
like uh uh just nasty to everybody like
oh y'all like
first we were the good guys in the jump
shooting team that a jump shooting team
would never win now all of a sudden
we're the super villains yeah it's
switched absolutely super villains and
so that one was like oh we're the super
villains well all right say no more
there's nothing y'all can do about it
then you go into 2018. wait so first
one's disbelief second one is just super
villain okay what's three you you you're
going into into
um
2018
and that one is like okay now we're
coming back and we need to stamp what we
did last year like everybody's still
talking we win the first championship
with Katie everybody got something to
say uh Kevin she did he did this he
joined them and blah blah blah let's go
do it again and piss them off even more
and so I think that one was kind of like
the icing on the cake for all of it like
let's go do it again and
once we won that one the mindset
immediately turns to like well why not
three feet like
we haven't seen that why not three
people
obviously all the injuries happen and
we're we're not able to accomplish that
but the fourth one
the fourth one was like the biggest [ __ ]
you
I'm not even sure if I can curse or you
can't curse but that's I I have no
better way of explaining it that was
[ __ ] you to everybody
everybody who said we couldn't do it uh
for those that are even on our side and
didn't believe we could do it anymore
that was like the biggest [ __ ] you to
everybody that didn't believe that said
you know no disrespect to KD what Katie
came here and did was incredible but
that said when KD left we wouldn't win
again as if we didn't win before like
all of the uh Clay's now coming back
from two injuries he'll never be the
same
draymond's washed and he's old and blah
blah blah Steph doesn't have help
that was like the biggest [ __ ] you to
everybody because no one no Stephen A
did but most people did not take us to
win and
that one was just like
shut up like you you do not have the
right to talk anymore like for all of
you that said there was no chance for
all of you that are supposed to be
experts that just don't get it like you
don't understand what makes up the sauce
it was just like okay you can shut up
now thank you have a good day what makes
up the sauce
number one
um
there's winners and there's losers and I
I think people
don't realize that like
just because you're talented doesn't
make you a winner
um
if I'm being quite honest most super
talented guys are losers
a vast majority of them are losers and
so there's winners and there's losers
and
you have to understand what makes up a
winner why do you win like what's
burning inside that's when and I think
for us what's what's been so great and
successful for us is that
that's always been the most important
thing and we're going to compete
I think one of the biggest things that
that makes up
is to never get rattled like
but you we go in these playoffs and like
we we literally know down to the T like
we're walking the locker room be like yo
this one over like we got them figured
out now they ride up and so and you
literally just watch guys shrink in the
moment year after year after year after
year you watch guys shrink and I think
having that DNA of like
just not shrinking in the moment and
like welcoming those moments and never
being rattled
that's a part of our makeup and and if
I'm being honest that has won us some
championships and
I think that's really been driven by
Steve like I've never seen Steve in the
playoff series rattle ever seen him
Rattle and you take on that and so I
think you know like that is the biggest
ingredient is just never being rattled
by any situation no matter what it is
you stand in there ten toes down and you
watch the other team fold because I'm
telling you I've watched teams get the
two wins and four one win and four I've
watched team against the three wins and
four
but you confess your bottom dollar they
gonna fold yeah and you just gotta stay
the course and most people can't do that
they start bickering at each other it's
this guy's fault it's that guy's spot no
I'll just stay solid we'll be all right
clay played bad last night oh well yeah
oh man Draymond was awful game three oh
well nobody tripping what are we gonna
do game four steps gonna come I'll carry
the torch we got it no problem like the
belief you'll always figure it out
absolutely okay I have like 80 million
follow-ups because I thought that's
fascinating but what you said when you
said talented people aren't doesn't make
you a winner just because you have the
talent just because you have the
capability I don't mean a name but can
you give me an example of what you mean
by that because I think there's a lot of
Truth to that well I think we see a lot
of talent to losers in this league you
know you see guys that go out
score a bunch of points
put up great numbers
they may lose by 30 or win by 30.
with those same numbers I'm sorry but if
your number is already exact same and
you lose by 30 and win by 30.
you got a question what's going on with
those numbers now at times you can look
around and say didn't get much help
right like and that happens yeah but
you got to compete on the defensive end
no matter how talented you are
you got to compete on the defensive end
because if not you're going to get in
the playoff series and they're going to
single that out you got to compete on
that side of the ball it can't just be
about one side of the ball we see a lot
of that in this league you know we see a
lot of um
guys when it's not going right
especially overtowering to God overly
talent to God start pointing the finger
and blaming others but you're so
talented and you're that guy
how are you going to start pointing the
finger now like you can't start pointing
the finger because you're that good
right like you are that's what the hype
says that's what where you've been
curious but the moment you go wrong now
it's that guy's father and it's that
guy's fault
yeah you're talented to lose her you
know and so
like I said I've seen it
year after year around this league and
quite frankly if I'm being honest guys
get glorified for it you know they get
glorified for
oh man look at the numbers look at this
time you get glorify for it and
no meanwhile I'm just sitting there
watching like yeah that's cool now when
you get them playoffs that that one
gonna fold right there I can see it from
a mile away I wonder though
then is that something that can be
taught
right like
is that who you are
or can you be taught to be this winner
can you be taught to not be shaken like
or is it there's the people that have it
and there's the people that do not have
it well I I do think there are people
that have it and I think there are
people that don't but I'll give you an
example
just 18 months ago they were saying
Andrew Wiggins was that very true
everyone counted out Andrew Wiggins bus
yeah like Sunday school don't compete
um just gonna go scores points and relax
blah blah blah
we know all of the things that they said
so
that would bring me to say
either
you have it
and you just needed someone to pull it
out of you
or
it can be taught
because that is one case study that
everyone counted out
you haven't
you don't hear a bad word about Andrew
Wiggins nowadays which is absolutely
amazing like
makes me extremely happy
but
either
you've been around some other losers and
it's contagious changes they couldn't
bring it up or
it can be taught
I don't know I think I think some guys
do just have it and like that should
make up that's your DNA that's just what
you're about
there are others that it needs to be
pulled out and you got to constantly
pull it out but
I don't know if it's on me to say
whether he had it and we needed to pull
it out or he learned it yeah but it's
one of the two because that was not the
sentiment around him 18 months ago
absolutely but I so and I agree with
what you're saying but just for the sake
of the topic and the argument right to
play devil's advocate here to me that is
about situation because somebody else
might argue well he was able to become a
winner
because he's with you all so there might
be some people that feel like okay they
have the talent they have the capability
but they just literally don't have the
situation and I think there's just this
balance between when is it the singular
person and when is it the setting that
that person is being put into and can
they Thrive or can they not
does that make sense what I'm saying I
think I think 100 makes sense and I
think situation is important for
everybody right like you can take the
best scene CEO in the world and you go
dump him in a in an organization full of
losers and people that don't work hard
and people that don't understand the
vision and he's only going to be as
successful as those peoples that that's
working underneath them yeah or she is
only going to be successful as those
people that's working underneath her and
so I I when
like situation I think that's important
for everyone nobody in this league is
going out there and winning games by
themselves it's just never happening
um I think you know one that I always
talk about is organizations absolutely
you know no one ever blames organization
it's always the guy's fault it's this
kid's fault it's that kid's fault they
can't figure it out no one ever said
that is a [ __ ] organization
um not specifically talking about
Wiggins but you're saying in German no
one ever blames organizations at all
it's always even though they literally
make the decisions yeah exactly and by
the way when you do well then they take
the credit but also sometimes I think
that's by Design
well 100 yeah yeah
absolutely yeah so
um I think situation is important for
everyone now in saying that though
it's not like Wiggins came here last
year and we often won a championship no
he ended up being a part of that team
that won 15 games he was also part of
that team that
um that lost two playing games but then
you ask yourself the question what did
that experience do yes right like oh you
got to feel like what it feels like just
a little bit how did that push you for
that next year right you know and so
you also
kind of a victim to circumstance as well
sometimes it works in your favor
sometimes it doesn't and I think you
know in his case okay it worked in his
favor but it wasn't like it was the
championship team of old and and he was
just plugged in and we no we had to
rebuild a championship team and go do it
again and he was a huge part of that so
I don't I can't sit and say that it was
situation because every team every year
has its own challenges and no one's
situation is just the same where you can
be plugged in and you just go well we've
seen that done before years and years of
people trying to go to Team and win and
it don't work you know so you have to
build that thing and I can't say it's
just situation because if that was the
case way more people would be Champions
that's fair it's like can you come in
and kind of make the environment adapt
to you like can you thrive within that
situation Fair absolutely I don't know
if you're a person that thinks about
history and where you stand in it but if
you are do you ever think about
what y'all's big three right if you
Steph and Clay means in the broader
sense of basketball
um
think about it at times
because I understand it from the ground
up right like I understand it from
laying the first brick
showing up
eight weeks before training camp as a
rookie and Mark Jackson has his entire
staff Darren Herman
working with us on defense like we're
spending an hour on hour and a half
literally on defense not touching the
ball because they were 29th to 30th in
the league in defense the year before
and they're like we're going to be a top
five defense no matter what and like
we're spending an hour hour and a half
on defense
I can still look back and understand and
see like those first bricks being laid
wear the game of basketball was then and
where it is now and where it is now but
in understanding every step along the
way how I was changing all of a sudden
like I said I will never forget
and Charles was a big corporate
shooting teams can't win championships
they will never you live by the three
you die
what is the last time you heard live by
the three die by the three right and so
that's the Stefan clay thing right you
live by the three you're gonna die by
the three of them brothers ain't dead
yet it's been a long time ago yeah
that's long lived so everybody's
shooting three so it don't look like
they're gonna die no time so yeah yeah
okay so you got that when I came in the
league
there was this word being tossed around
and I was labeled it and it was almost
like a death sentence
and it was the word tweener when's the
last time you heard the word Twitter
yeah right thing now but it was
absolutely it was adoption yeah I mean I
would never you didn't want the label no
it was awful yeah
now they're looking for tweeners and
they don't call them that anymore right
and so it's like and understanding why
did that change well no one will ever
say your favorite Power Forward wasn't
dribbling the ball up to court before I
started bringing the ball up to court
and running offense nobody nobody's ever
going to say that probably because I'm
just a hated man and it's okay but
if you won't say that
just know I know you don't know
basketball and that's okay too because
we all can't know basketball I always
talk about that like everyone doesn't
know basketball so
if you can't go back and look back at
NBA basketball if you may have missed
what you were watching
we'll just say you may not know
basketball and that's okay so then
not doing a ranking situation but when
you think of like those other top
victories I think something about you
all is you did genuinely change the way
the basketball was played but what are
the other big threes that you're like
okay they might have us though because
of what they were able to do well I
think because I'm just so interested in
the story that history will tell about
the Warriors is gonna be fascinating to
me I think it's going to be incredible
but when I look at other big threes I
don't necessarily look at them and say
oh man they have this on us or they have
that on us because quite frankly I I
think it's just it's it's almost
impossible to compare like if you look
at the Lakers everybody's going to say
Shaq and Kobe right like
but Derek Fisher was so important to
those teams and they couldn't win
without Derek Fisher yeah is that a big
three or is it not because Derek Fisher
wasn't averaging this many points as
say Shaq and Kobe was averaging right
and so you look at but then you look
deeper into the Lakers history you talk
magic Kareem big game yeah like
I mean I I love our Victory right like
it's incredible and what we've done is
absolutely amazing but magic Kareem and
James Worthy I'm sorry yeah
I mean that's just a totally different
yeah but I mean that's that's not a bad
one if you're right you know you look
good they earn that like you look at D
Wade bronze and Bosch and it's like
I wouldn't necessarily pick them over us
but as a basketball mind
if I if if you say well
we're going to pick we're going to put
these three up against each other
I'm probably gonna pick them
not because I
Basha 611
LeBron is six nine there's just facts
yeah d-way six four yeah 225
physically
they got us over match now
so as a basketball mind I'm saying oh
I'm picking them
but then that's where also on the flip
side of basketball Minds now
understanding all that goes into it
right and so with all that goes into it
the mental toughness not bending on each
other not pointing a finger on each
other you know how many times I've went
into the media and like tried to take
blame for myself to like take the blame
for Steph and clay
do you know how many times staff has
gone into the media and taken the plan
for me and clay
clay will go and like
I just need to be better like and Clay
is never going to say as much as Steph
and I will but my point being
we're never going to go throw the next
one under the bus you know we're never
going to go blame the next guy we gonna
shoulder and be like Oh I'm gonna go do
this and I know he gonna fall in line
because I have that trust in him and I
know if I go on the Foxhole them two
gonna follow me in there or vice versa
and so
as a basketball mind you look at all
those physical tunes and you're like I'm
picking those guys I as a basketball
mind will pick those guys too but when
you get down to it to the nitty-gritty I
ain't picking nobody
over us three now I know I probably
confused everybody and now it's kind of
the setup of like big game and and and
and the heaters and all of that but
I don't think any of those guys and it's
no disrespect to them I don't think any
of those guys have the makeup that we
have
in part due to not not that they're not
physically tough not that they're not
mentally tough
but they don't though none of those guys
face the same challenges that we Face
undersized undersized
um stuff yeah like Clay is about the
only one that has like great size Rich
positions yeah other two we're
undersized
um one was Steph was too slow and
handles weren't good enough and Clay
couldn't dribble good enough and I was
just way too fat and too slow with no
position like those groups those groups
didn't face any of that yeah tweeners
and that's why I'm picking us so I know
I touched on this but this big three
obviously has been very important to
basketball but even more important to
the Warriors as an organization and you
guys are really the foundation of this
kind of two timeline plan that the
Warriors have talked about
as a player though what are the benefits
of that type of plan and what are the
challenges with that type of plan
um
I think as a as a player for me the
benefits are the relationships that you
build with these young guys right the
relationship that I have with Moses
Moody I cherish
bye
the relationship that I've built with
Tai Jerome I cherish the relationship
that I've built with Jonathan Kamina I
cherish like I enjoy trying to show
those guys the way like getting James
Wiseman to open up and talk like every
time he see me he like Drake what's up
he come up to me he come up to me having
conversations about life
that's special
and so when I look at the benefits of it
that's the biggest benefit to me is you
have the opportunity to help guy and
steer these young guys future
that is special you know that's like
that's what Jared Jack did for us that's
what Jermaine O'Neal did for us and Carl
Landry and David Lee and Andrew Bogan
like Richard Jefferson
they're like oh
and then he started helping steer us I
give so much joy out of trying to help
steer these young guys and show them
that now you shouldn't do that you
should do that this way or think about
this this way not necessarily that you
should go but maybe just think about
this this way and then if you think
about it that way tell me what you come
up with yeah you know right like
allowing them to hide their own brain
but teaching them how to think teaching
them how to process teaching them how to
watch film
[Music]
those aren't benefits and the biggest
benefit for me because quite frankly
also
I'll be gone from here one day player
will be gone stuff will be gone but
building those things
building those relationships they'll go
far past hey you know how much like how
happy it makes me and I'm sure it makes
them when I I walk out and I get to see
Jared Jack and he's a coach for another
team yeah not that it's just like I'm so
proud of him but like that's my best
yeah that's my OG you know and so
that's the special part of it now
the disadvantages of it is
it's a disadvantage for us but it's even
more of a disadvantage for those guys
which is they don't unders they don't
come in understanding basketball at the
level that we need them to understand
that for the level that we've played and
played right and it's a disadvantage for
us because you're trying to teach and
play and on the Fly get this guy in the
right position and this that another
but for them
it's even more of a disadvantage yeah
because because it's kind of always
ketchup exactly you're playing ketchup
everybody's expecting you to come in
think about this
Moses Moody at 19 years old Jonathan
coming at 19 years old James Wiseman at
19 years old are all expected or when
they were 19.
to come in and compete
the level that we compete at
we compete at a higher level
than your favorite player in the NBA
yeah
yeah those guys come in and never
expected right away or stick out like a
sore thumb yeah
that you're supposed to be able to
compete at the level that Steph could be
sad and that you're supposed to be able
to shoot at the level that clay shoots
at right and you're supposed to be able
to defend at the level and understand
the game at the level that I that's
impossible right it's impossible
but that's what they're up against
and no one has compassion for them right
no one as they did oh man those young
guys aren't ready blah blah blah it's
like no you're here buckle up yeah no
more has compassion no one says Jonathan
can mean is the seventh pick
you look at just about any other seven
pick they're going to a team that stinks
yeah they're going to a team demand one
that's probably lottery every year
trying to figure it out that and guess
what they get to go there and shoot all
the balls and grow through their
mistakes and get better as a player and
improve not on national TV right like
you make it one National TV game a year
on League fast which League Pass is
great but it's not National TV like you
know Jonathan's experience is much
different like than what you would think
James why yeah number two pick yeah it's
getting judged too
they also got lucky though
I mean I think you you you you create
your luck the work that they put in they
created no I'm saying they got lucky
that their experience was with the
Warriors that they learned how to be
winners that they were able to do all
that it's hard but the hard paid off but
it's twofold though because if you ask
most people in in sports
they would tell you that Jonathan comiga
still hasn't learned how to win they
would tell you that Moses muli still
hasn't learned how to win and that they
were only on a team with Steph and clay
and Draymond and that's why they were
able to win a championship so they don't
get the benefit of like oh you win and
won a championship now when you get down
to it as you go on your career like I
won a championship and no one could take
that away from you but they don't get
the benefit of like oh you know how to
win because you won a championship they
don't get that but for an early pick I'd
rather be with the Warriors is what I'm
saying that's where the luck aspect
comes from I mean in a sense yes
but what about when you're getting
bashed every single day at 19 mm-hmm
when it ain't looking so good yeah it
looked great at the end when you're
hosting the trophy but what about
everything that you've been going
through all year because everybody
expect that you number seven picking you
just supposed to figure it out right
away with this championship team like
what about all of that that you're going
through and so in the end yes it pays
off but while you're going through it
that way like yeah what you're going
through it is just like like you can't
catch a break you almost feel snake
bitten you gonna miss a rotation dude
this stuff happen this game happening so
fast yeah like
he's like hey you're going to miss a
rotation I'm sorry there's no way you're
going to see that coming this game is
happening so fast but he's just like I
missed the rotation right
and so I think it's it's a twofold thing
and as much of a disadvantage as that
could be for us that time it's an even
bigger disadvantage for them and no one
has compassion for them about it no
that's fair when you were explaining
that though you said you know there's
going to be a day that I'm not here is
it hard for you to say that like there
will be a day that you maybe aren't a
warrior no no
no because
um
quite frankly the writings on the wall
and
I understand the business
and
we tend to get into this mindset of
someone owes us something because of
what we've accomplished
but those someone's on the other side
don't feel that way so you be an idiot
to walk around feeling that way like I
feel like you're just setting yourself
up
for failure you're setting yourself up
for heartbreak you're setting yourself
up for disappointment as opposed to
saying no let me learn this business let
me understand the business side of this
and if you understand the business side
of it for me when I say to writing on
the wall
that's that's why that's what I mean
when I say the right I understand the
business of basketball I spend a lot of
time like talking to Rich Paul like
about the business and learning more and
more and more about the business side of
things and if you spend your time doing
that which I think all should like I
think it's crazy to be in the business
and not understand the ins and outs yeah
I mean but it's very common
I don't get it but it is very common
but if you don't if if you don't get to
know the business then you can be
blindsided and be like oh man I well
everything I've done there I thought I'd
be there forever
I quite frankly I don't think I will be
I would love to be but I also understand
the business I understand the luxury tax
I understand you got these young guys
and contracts up and they have to get
paid like I understand all of those
things and so just for me when I say the
writers on the wall
that's what I mean by the writers on the
wall is that I just understand the
business side and when are you when you
can remove your emotions because
there was a time where I was very
emotional about this and I couldn't have
this very conversation with you about
this topic I was very emotional but I
had to take a step back and say let me
take a step outside of this and remove
my emotions and let me put my thinking
cap on let me put my business cap on and
when I put that business Capital it was
literally noticed with the hey dude
you'd be an idiot if you're about to go
into this emotional side because just
look at the business look at the books
and if you look at the books and you
look at the business you get a better
understanding now are there ways around
that could that possibly change
absolutely would I love to be here yes
but in looking at the business for me
and my understanding I just don't think
so when was that time you said there is
a time that I was emotional I couldn't
have had this conversation and then I
learned to like remove my emotions Last
Summer
after winning the championship
I was very emotional about it
how so
I was just upset
because one side of me is looking at the
business side like I don't know how this
is going to play out and I don't think
I'm going to be on the right side of the
way this plays out
the other side of me is looking at like
man I've won four championships here in
10 years an organization that couldn't
couldn't beat my high school team for
years like
I should be here and they should commit
to me as long as I'm playing because of
what I've done here and like that's the
human side of it right like that's the
competitive side that's the
um
we've had success and I'm feeling myself
a little bit side right
but I knew I had to take a step outside
of that if I really wanted to understand
and so I just spent the time and like
try to remove my emotions from it and
when I remove my emotions I was able to
see a different side of it
but I was real emotional about it at
first yeah very emotional about it so
when you're talking about it it's like
you're like I was very emotional I
remember vividly last summer you were
emotional how did that play out in your
life
um I think it played out in my life uh I
have a very close relationship with Bob
and I think Bob could tell you like he
said he was emotional but I would tell
you like
one day my conversation was like
and like a week later my conversation
probably looked like this yeah
and he's like and he said to me
he's like yo what happened
and I was like oh you know I just had to
like do some sorrow soul searching and
like like think about this stuff and
like really
opened my mind to what's in front of me
and not sit here and and think about it
from the standpoint of I've accomplished
this and we've done this and we're old
this and I said once I once I stepped
outside of that
like I said it was very easy for me
to move to where I am now once I remove
my emotions about it which is a journey
and like a learning experience always
absolutely it's probably never
completely over
but you always can get better and better
but you're learning about yourself your
entire life 100 yeah and you know what's
crazy is
over the last few years I've done a lot
of learning about myself and I feel like
I have some years where I stopped
learning about myself
and
sure enough during that time I kind of
stopped liking myself you know like
because I wasn't getting better I felt
very stagnant I felt like
just like ah like just in one spot not
growing like and the reality is if you
ain't growing you're declined it yeah
and so I just didn't feel like I was
doing the work and like kind of getting
lost in this revolving door that we all
live in in the Sports World and like man
like
you gotta lock in and focus and like
read more and like start back doing the
personal work
and like I've enjoyed it but it's a
journey do you like yourself now I love
myself now like I feel like I've grown
so much and don't get me wrong I've
always loved myself like
trust me there's no shortage of love but
no I feel you're like when I you're like
when I would sit and think about who I
was I just didn't know is this a person
I'd want to be around exactly yeah
exactly and it's like you know from like
I thoroughly enjoy myself and like but
but on the on the other side of that I
thoroughly enjoy working on myself and
so I feel like because of that I'm
constantly growing and learning
and that's fun and it's challenging and
like there's something to wake up to
every day and like do you know and like
chase after and like
just be on this this constant journey of
like being your best self that you can
be and so
I enjoy that and and with that comes a
ton of mistakes yeah like
daily mistakes
but I enjoy working through them I get
no better feeling than like feeling like
I'm working through some of my mistakes
and like coming out on the other side of
them there's no better feeling because I
know and I understand
the time that I had to spend in order to
do that yeah and I know you know that
daily work and that that understanding
of who you are and the mistakes you make
and how you can become better it's
something that I know that you take
really seriously and so then I know that
you were really working on reflecting
and about who you can be and who you
have been
and I know obviously when the Jordan
pool video came out there was a lot of
chatter about that video but when you
watch that video
how do you feel about yourself
well when I watched the video
when that video first came out I watched
that video
all day
go to it watch it watch it over and over
again
leave it go do something else come back
to the video watched again
because that video had me forming a pen
about myself
and I was sitting there and as someone
who who was involved in the incident
I totally forgot and watching that video
everything that went on
because in the video you watch an audio
this video you watch a three second clip
of me walking up and I swing and like
that's what you see
that video was put out there like that
to portray me the exact way it did
does that mean I was not wrong in what I
did
no
that does not mean that
100 was the wrong reaction
but in everything there's also a full
story
I don't care to share my story
one day I will
it ain't the time nor the place nor do I
care to share it care more about
figuring this team out and trying to win
but one day I will
because there's always a Time
but what I what I figured out and
watching that video for all day is like
damn
this is this actually was what this was
meant to do like this was meant to form
an opinion about me
and not give another side to it like not
even allow another opinion to be formed
this video was put out just like this
no audio
if we got this video we got the whole
practice right like we got everything
right
all you see is what five seconds
and so what I had to do is number one
and
because like once that release I'm I'm
experiencing so many emotions right like
I'm I'm upset like how the hell just
this get released
I'm like
Going Through Hell
because you're I mean
just at the sole discretion of public
opinion
and
on the flip side of that also dealing
with my team
whose sentiments also changed once the
video came up
so here you are here I am
in a situation where
everybody was there everyone attended
whatever was going to be was going to be
and then the video comes out and
everything changes
and so now I'm like wow
that's what this was intended to do
that's why this was released this way
and so in going through every emotion
and experiencing all the different
emotions that I was experiencing
in order for me to even start to unpack
this whole thing
I have to look at it from every point of
view like I can't just go in like well
this is the point of view I'm a I'm
gonna look at it from and that's it like
you come out very short-sighted like you
come out with not all the facts you come
out with
um not a complete understanding because
you didn't look at a complete picture
and so
I had to start looking at this thing
from like so many different viewpoints
and trusting different people viewpoints
that I trust you know
um trust in some people Viewpoint that I
don't trust like and just really using
that
to kind of dissect and unpack this whole
thing
and in doing that
it really led me to some different
spaces but like I said one of those
spaces being
this was this this was put out like this
to to form that opinion on me that it
did so just a clarifying question
because I'm curious I I can I can't tell
if this is what you're being insinuated
I don't want to be wrong
the video coming out you feel like was
like
calculated thing for the video to come
out 100 percent
you ain't never seen another video from
our practice
that camera got to be on every day right
or was it just on that day in that
moment for those five seconds
you see one of our players drawing that
that we drawing up in practice coming
out from those videos you ain't seen
anything else coming out from practicing
those videos
so it's 100 calculated
who was it calculated by I don't know I
would still love to know that answer I
still don't have an answer how the video
got released
not sure I will ever get an answer
be honest with you I'm not even in
search of an answer I would love to know
but I ain't chasing after for what it's
a wasting my time
what happened happened
um I accepted my responsibility in it
and once I recept once I accepted my
responsibility and I started to move
forward like I accepted my
responsibility I knew I was wrong I
apologized to those that I needed to
apologize to
and now it's time to do the work and
move forward and so in saying that I'm
not going to spend a bunch of time going
to try to figure out right who who
released it because it's behind me you
know and
and I wanted to stay behind me I don't
want to put that back in front of me so
um but it's 100 a calculated Thing by
whoever released it or whoever was
behind it is 100 calculated I wish I
knew the answer of who it was calculated
by but it's definitely calculated
so with you and I know obviously I
listened to your podcast talking about I
saw the PC did on TNT and like taking
the responsibility of being wrong in the
video that what you did you know and I
honestly don't really know the question
to ask because we don't know what
happened and you know and that's not a
thing you want to share and that's
totally fine
but with the information that we have
presented to us from what we saw in the
video do you think that you all have
been able to be in this space to move
forward do you think that you have shown
to Jordan based on what we have seen
that you are sorry that you want to move
forward that it can
be put behind you ah
[Music]
we go to work every day together
our lockers are right next to each other
that never changed
we ride the same buses together
we changing the same locker room on the
road together we
none of that has changed
did it change our relationship of course
absolutely
that's still a work in progress
I'll always be willing to continue to do
that work because I was wrong
and so in saying all of that
yes like definitely allowed to move
forward and we have moved forward and
it's been just fine
foreign
but it's a different 100 percent
and not that I expected it to be the
same right like
if I had to say back then like oh I
think this would go like this or I think
it'll go like that
I can't say it's went very different or
it's been very far off from the way I
thought it would go
um
I think it's been pretty close to the
way that I thought it would go
but as far as like us moving forward
we've definitely moved forward
and
and I see improvements
day by day week by week by month I see
improvements that's good and that's all
you can ask for you know um I don't
expect him to come out and be like man I
want to come hang with you off the court
and like I don't expect that like I'm
not I'm not a fool like I grew up in
Saginaw Michigan that advice before like
I'm in this situations before I know how
you come out of those situations like
it's not what I expected so
in saying that
it's kind of what I expected it to be
but it's a constant work in progress
because it's very important to the
makeup of our team to the success of our
team
and so I continue to do the work yeah
so
separate from
everything that happened in the video
you said something I thought was
interesting which is
it allowed people to form an opinion of
you what do you think is the disconnect
between who you actually are
and what you think people think about
you well I think people judge you based
off what they see on a basketball court
which I always say to people if I came
to you and I came and sat down in your
job
and I watched you work what opinion
would I form about you
for most people
it won't be
the opinion I'll form about you if I'm
just sitting in a room with you talking
and kicking it with you having a drink
or whatever
it wouldn't be the same we're paying for
and if so you're probably you probably
suck at your goddamn job in my opinion
if you is going to be the same
in everything that you do like then
where's the separation is so you're not
working hard like something's not not
really adding up and so I think
um
what people do is they they watch me
working then they form this opinion on
who I am as a person
and it couldn't be so much further from
the truth and really shows how dumb
people are
um
that they formed their opinion and think
the same person that I watched take the
basketball for every night with the
Golden State Warriors that's who that
guy is like I have people like hitting
my wife up like oh my God I know he's
beating you at home and he's beating on
your kids and I'm like wait that's what
you took away from that like yeah
what like you took away that's crazy
from me getting into altercation and my
job in a a very high testosterone
environment like
you took away from that that I beat on
my kids and my wife
how could you possibly take that away
from that you know and so
the disconnect is
basketball is entertainment
although I played basketball to win
It's Entertainment
and a part of who we are entertainers
you have to be like it's a show we put
we go out and we put on the show
night in and night out
I'm not sure what the disconnect is for
people
to be honest because I don't try to
figure it out because I can really care
less
um
thank you if you are someone that see me
on a basketball court and you walk away
from there thinking that guy is an
[ __ ] I don't like him
I'm glad you feel that way because I
don't need to talk to you because
like why would I need to talk to you
like if that's when you walk away from
it with like
number one you you're so far off
understanding me and what I do anyway to
where I don't really care to explain it
to you or get you to know and so
I don't really know what the disconnect
is
um
but they're saying that I I know I've
won a lot of and and one thing people
hate winners
yeah
quite frankly because most people are
losers
so I know you're saying like you you
don't like it doesn't matter to you
right well someone says about you and I
think that that is the um no it matters
yeah that's just I think I think that
that's the attitude that like you want
to have but I think it's an impossible
attitude to have all of the time because
I think it's a human want
for people to like you I just think
that's that's just the fact of it
so when these times where you're feeling
like maybe everyone's against you or
they think that you're this person is
there like a sadness that comes with
that
no more it definitely matters
um
it will never not matter I just think
for me personally
I'm definitely not going to spend time
trying to figure it out it's that's a
total waste of time and so
that's where it's kind of like where
you're kind of like man it is what it is
I don't care it's not that I don't care
that someone doesn't like me is that I
don't care
to try to figure out why you don't
because if I had to do that then I'll be
spending my life doing that
and so I think it's more so
that
um is there a sadness that comes with it
I wouldn't necessarily say a sadness but
I will say it's unpleasant at times
all right I'll give you an example
Trey Young
who I am a big fan of mohawks I like
Larry Atlanta there it is like
I'm a big fan of Treyon he's talented as
hell
Underdog small
all of that
but because of his stature
you're going to want to like him before
you want to hate him
and I personally think Trey has in his
mind he's taken on this villain role
and he's bought into it and he has Dove
half first in
he's good enough to take it on
and still play well and still be Trey
young and still be an All-Star and be
fine
but I personally think it's the wrong
approach
um why because being a villain ain't fun
you only get so much out of tell us like
I out of shutting someone up
like how many times you're going to shut
them up and then like then what then
what they still hate you you're still
like that as the villain and blah blah
blah
I have kids you don't know how that's
gonna affect them how people make and so
it's like it's just no fun like it's fun
at times don't get me wrong it has its
moments where yeah you're like well yeah
I love it and enjoying every minute
minute of it but overall
that ain't no fun like yeah forcing
people to not like you and like
and so I think
like for a guy like Trey like nah man go
the opposite way
like
go to go the opposite way not that
you're like in search of someone liking
you because that's wrong too like you
shouldn't be in search of someone liking
you but
but you're saying like almost don't
intentionally make life harder exactly
like because
because it doesn't just make life harder
on the basketball court
I can make life harder all the way
around because again that same judgment
that same judgment just walks with you
and
the first year the underdog and you're
the villain and you take on that role
and everybody love it and very soon
after then it becomes distasteful they
hate it they hate you they're slandering
you they're slandering your name and all
of this and so it's like it has a quick
moment of like where it's cool and it's
fun
but then it it goes astray and
you're just kind of stuck in this space
so
I
I totally agree right that who you are
as a human is not here on the basketball
court I know you so I know what you're
actually like
but I'm wondering because I'm a big
advocate for therapy I talk about it a
lot on the show one thing when I was
going to therapy that I say is this
accountability aspect of life
so if you zoom out
and you think about your life
what role do you think that you have
played in maybe the negative things that
people think about you
I've played a huge role in it
like
a very big role in him
but I'm also not upset about it either
because I also don't think I'm sitting
here doing this interview with you
if I didn't play as big a role in it if
I didn't if I was not the villain if I
wasn't
um you know throughout my career
um
if I did not have that same chip on my
shoulder like like the Persona I'm six
five and three quarters
I make your nearest seven footer look
like a
little dude all right that's hard
well with that comes like you just like
I'm sorry but you just don't get all the
benefits and and not get the
the disadvantages to it as well like so
you got to take the good with the bad
and if I'm being honest my good severely
outweighs the bad like
out of a pretty good life
have a great family
I've built a great career
from now I'm moving forward like
so my it's not like the bad always the
good no like my my guts severely
outweighs the bad but
in saying that
I understand the role that I've played
in it
and if I'm being honest that at times
I've
said more into it
not much as of late
I'mma always talk [ __ ] like that's what
I do like that's me so that's never
going to stop so I if someone's gonna
see this and be like oh you're gonna
keep talking absolutely I mean if that's
what you taking and then great keep
taking because I'm never gonna stop
doing that
but I think on on the you know on the
other side of it
um
I've
I've caused a lot of it
but then there's also like the
circumstance and like reputational
things that
has affected it as well
that takes some things a step further
than they would for most
it can be the same exact thing
but because of
all the prior stuff and
it's not the same on this side although
the same we did the same thing on this
side but how it looks for me over here
and how it looks for someone else it's
not the same and that's uh
that can be challenging at times because
that takes some maturity for you to
understand and say okay
it's not the same
but then you have to be able to be
honest with yourself and say why is it
not the same and if you can't be honest
with yourself and tell yourself why it's
not the same
as hell
because then you sit in this space of
like not understanding and not like
not
really
believing what's right in front of you
and that's a tough place to be in
no that's interesting I just think it's
interesting like you you have that
presence of mind to know that like okay
Trey what you're doing it's going to
make your life harder but you don't have
the
time machine for you to go back and say
Draymond this way is going to make your
life harder you know and it's just like
now you kind of become the thing that
you would warn someone about does that
make sense 100 yeah I think
in raising my kids like some of the
things that I know that has made my life
harder I try to um
I try to correct those things with with
my kids like the moment I see him like
no no no don't do that like
and because I understand what that
particular thing did to me or for me or
against me
but then on the flip side you're like
but that thing also is the reason this
thing was created or that thing is the
reason I'm this way and blah blah blah
and trying to understand that and like
find that balance
[Music]
that's one of the everyday struggles for
me in parenting
and no one like
yeah you need some of this to get there
some of this may come with that thing
and I know how that thing hurt me so
like then what's the right answer right
that's the right thing to show what's
the right thing to teach
that that's that's one of my biggest
struggles as a parent that I feel like I
live with daily yeah being a parent I
can't imagine
that's crazy yeah it's just always like
every decision you feel like you're
making is like the biggest decision
because you're literally shaping the
lives of like these people that you love
more than anything on the planet it's
like I feel like it would just consume
every single thing that you do and that
is the kicker right like
having a kid Maybe
I always say
you'll say like
y'all die from my mom
we are upset I know I have
I am 100 certain my mom would die for me
but what I am 100 also 100 certain
numbers that I would die for mine
that love as a parent
is totally different
totally different
and
yet
it's hard
but it's so rewarding because like you
said you're you're helping shape the
life
like I was talking about the rookies
earlier like how you can help guide them
and help shape their future like having
kids is like that to the 1000 degrees
Yeah
degree but also I have to say that that
Jason Tatum came on my show last summer
I think yeah and we're talking about him
being a dad and he he said exactly he
was like I Now understand like the movie
John Q yes he's like because in a
heartbeat
I'm dying for Deuce like that no problem
like yeah
I my kids no problem
oh by the way go enjoy like have a blast
you'll miss me but
but in a heartbeat yeah but that love is
different and it's crazy because when I
had kids
I understood I I understood and
understand my mom so much more yeah than
I did before like there used to be
things that my mom would get mad at me
when I was a kid and I'm like man that's
like why are you mad yeah like that's
nothing you're like Mom I get it now I'm
sorry but like you you
have a kid and you realize how tied into
that kid that you are yeah and like the
smallest thing they do like it hurts
like because you just it more so hurts
from the standpoint I just don't want
you to have to deal with X or you know I
don't want you to get
um hit by why
because I know what comes if you get hit
by ax or Hippo
and and you're just hurt in part you
just don't want to see them suffer or
struggle or go through anything that's
not great
but it's challenging it's challenging I
love I mean I could literally sit here
and talk to you about this all day but I
think we only have you for 10 more
minutes so I do want to talk about
defense and I do want to play a little
game of fill in the blank but let's
start with defense
um because something that you said to me
I think about all the time when it comes
to just like talking about the game
thinking about the game you were like we
do not talk about defense the same way
we talk about offense
and we should
can you explain what you meant by that
to the viewers well I think um
when you look at when you look at
then the analysis side of basketball or
highlights let's just go high sorry
how often do you see defensive
highlights how often is a team is
an analyst analyzing A team's defensive
scheme or analyzing
um coverage or
unless you are absolutely incredible
analyzing the guys
defensive performance unless you were
off the charts
they don't but the reality is
defense has
as big if not bigger effect on the game
then that offense does the only
difference is
you have to score a point to win yeah so
I get it
but guess what
if you're good your defense can lead to
that offense you know like you
and when it's when it's doing that is I
mean
it's going good and
when I said I don't think people analyze
defense the same way they do offense
like
you can be an absolutely great defender
and if you have no offense again you may
not be in the NBA
but how many guys do you see in the NBA
that has good offensive skills or great
office and can't check
anybody yeah I can't check a soul yeah
I mean some people just don't play
defense right yeah yeah but guess what
most hardly no one doesn't just way off
it right
and so when you look at the game from
that perspective
it is also analyzed and viewed that way
defense is not viewed with the same
um
care or
it's it's not viewed in the same space
as offense
and quite frankly I don't understand why
I do understand why the reality is
I understand part of the reason why yeah
the reality is in order for you to sit
there and dissect the defense you have
to really know what's going on you have
to know rotations you have to try to
figure out what coverage someone is in
because
depending on the coverage that someone's
in it you may thought that person broke
down in reality it was this person that
broke down because of the way we regard
and say a thing
and I just have never for the life of me
understood
why
defense isn't judged with the same
with the same love gratitude whatever
you will word you want to use
as offense yeah because you were like I
remember you said to me you were like
there's no defensive situation where you
don't want me in the game that's a fact
and you said there's people you know
that have one defensive player of the
year that are finalists for defensive
player of the year and there are
situations that they can be in where
they're uncomfortable
you're like but there's no situation
that I get into you can't make me
uncomfortable in the offense
I'm sorry but there's no
situation
you wanna put me on the ball okay I'll
go guard the ball you want to put me as
the screener a gardener screener great I
can do that easy
or I'm guarding the ball and it's
there's a screen coming I know how to do
that too I need to go guard the post
I'll do that help side come on
um do it in my sleep all right yes
Blitz in the pick and roll okay I can go
Bliss he want me to play the backside of
the Blitz and kind of play I'm the Man
in the 403 crate I can do that no prob
like I don't feel like there's a there's
a
anything on the defensive end that you
can do to make me uncomfortable
there are guys on the defensive end that
gets a lot of credit for defense and you
can make them very uncomfortable very
fast for an entire game and I just don't
understand for the life of me if it's
like
if there was something that you can do
to Steph Curry
and make him uncomfortable on offense
time after time at the time again
we would not look at him as the same
offensive player as we do
because the first thing we'll say was oh
but all you got to do is guard them this
way and then he's done yeah
but the moment you do that on defense is
not viewed with that saying
this day
it's not viewed with
well if we just run this or we put this
guy in this action over and over again
they're going to struggle
it ain't viewed that way
and there there's some seasons
you're like
that dpoi should have been mine for sure
care to share when I'm probably sure two
or three hours Kawaii beat me and there
was no chance for Washington
one of the times that he won
now it's saying that Kauai is an
absolutely incredible Defender
great take nothing away from them
you put them on somebody he could go
lock him now as of late obviously
getting older injuries getting his
rhythm back different but at that time
absolutely amazing
but
I got Al Gort
I didn't even know wow didn't think I'd
be talking about Al Gore today
when that happened I had no idea you can
win like more first place votes and
still lose
weight all of those first place votes
and there's some ballots I didn't even
make the ballot like that don't even
make sense to me and so that right there
alone was like yeah that kind of don't
make sense
last year
it wasn't and by the way Marcus Smart
won it last year should have won last
year I'll find it
but when I got hurt it was like I was
like runaway Defensive Player of the
Year kind of didn't like nobody was in
second
and then I got hurt and I missed games
and like oh well but then I came back
and I picked up right back where I left
off at and then you'll say oh
well you play x amount of games I think
I played 47 or 48 games so my question
was
well what's the threshold because I also
lost to someone before they played 52
games
so what's the threshold 51 like how many
games this is the whole criteria
argument which is like what is I'm like
the rubric for voting right because I
know I passed the eye test like I mean
I'm destroying your favorite offense on
a nightly basis like
I know I passed the eye test so what is
it is it that I didn't play enough games
all right so if I play two more could I
have one
and so that's where it's kind of like
for me where like ah
it's a little off and skewed but is this
still like a goal like this year that's
a goal for you I assume it's probably
going it's always a goal yeah it's
always a goal of mine every year but I
don't feel like it validates me like I
don't feel like if if I win one more
defensive player you're two more defense
player three that is gonna make me know
more of a great defender than I already
am where as opposed to like
earlier in my career I probably felt
like I needed that for validation I
don't feel like it validates me anymore
I already know the team don't want me in
no action they're going to try to do
everything like I know the respect that
I have on that end I know what I'm
capable of on that end so the way it
used to bother me it don't bother me
anymore like if I was to win it great
like I would love to win it it's always
a goal
but if I win it nobody I don't I don't
feel like nobody's gonna say see and
he's an even better Defender now than he
was it's just a thing you put in your
pocket exactly okay last segment fill in
the blank you ready this is why you
can't tell your dream mom you end up
here three hours I'm like I could keep
on going okay fill in the link
a fifth NBA championship would represent
what to you a fifth NBA championship
would represent
who
a fifth one
to even think about five is crazy but I
think a fifth NBA championship like
I think if you if you had any doubt
it's just no more doubt but I already
feel like the dog is gone it's gone
it'll represent even less less okay
okay give me a good media answer here
you know you media Draymond don't give
me don't give me Warriors dream on
answer here
the team that will give the Warriors the
most problems this season is
the team that will get more is the most
problems this season
with the Brooklyn Nets
because they can shoot
they can shoot yeah they can defend
mm-hmm
they can play in half court
they can play in transition
want to make it an ISO game they can do
that just as good as anybody if not
better than everybody
they got the pieces
now
you know when the going gets tough you
got to see how you respond and react to
that yeah
they got the pieces
I like it okay uh a player you hate
matching up against the most is a player
that I hate matching up against the most
I don't really hate matching up against
anyone but I would say the player that
gives me the most trouble
is Darius Garland he's so Herky jerky I
love that answer at like
I hate guard DG I think that's the
player that like
I'm like ah
I'll guard him and I'm always sit on the
garden I'm never not I'm never ducking
no switch Yeah
but you gotta be willing to live with
something you're not just about to like
eat too early yeah and calves are fun
and I love Evan Mobley ah Evan Mobley's
a stuff oh no yeah like he's gonna be
one of the ones for real absolutely I
really like Evan Evan Moby wanted them
for certain all right three more another
Grizzlies Warriors playoff would be
another Warriors win
I knew you're gonna see
I love that matchup I just think it's so
much that's so cool right like it's fun
it's you know point guards jaw young
Uncle point guard versus staff blah blah
blah
rivalry
well the other thing I think that's
interesting about that whole thing too
is like fans don't understand that
basketball players this is basketball
like you and jaw don't dislike each
other you know what I mean like there's
a very strong mutual respect that exists
between you two the fans are like oh my
God they hated each other they're gonna
match up it's like no it's it's
basketball they understand the
competition of it and they love that but
then they move on so but don't hate them
at all actually
got a lot of love yeah a lot of love and
respect just how you carry himself how
he like I said the one of the biggest
things for me is how he make those guys
believe in themselves and him like in
their team like just how he make them
believe that's a that's a skill yeah and
it takes respect to do that so I got I
got a lot of love in Richmond yeah no
they would all like run through a wall
for him this year's MVP will be
this year's MVP will be
hmm that's an interesting one
it also might be early it gets a little
it is early yeah and the reason I think
it's early is because
I mean let's face it right like your
team has to do well and there's just
there's so many teams just like
jumbled and like no separation
that one team could take off like I
think Steph Steph has played at an MVP
level but our record does not
state that currently but we're also not
so far off to where that can't change
and then if that does change could Steph
be the MVP but if things stood as they
stand today I think who's who the MVP is
probably Joker again like which is wild
it's wild but the stuff that is he about
to average a triple double and no it's
wild all right it's wild
I mean he he incredible I think it'll be
him again because they're winning
they're in first place in the West
um and his numbers got better yeah okay
last one
what if you were not an NBA player you'd
be
if I was not an NBA player
well I'm not going to be an NBA player
at some point soon I mean not soon but
eventually yeah
I'm closer to the end than I am the
beginner put it that way yeah
um
I wanna I'm gonna do a lot in television
and feel and so not just
um
Sports analysts work like I I absolutely
love that not just podcasting but I want
to do
some different things in television and
film as well and so
possibly a director oh I love that being
behind the camera producing writing and
directing absolutely I think I think
directing people is one of my strengths
though and so if I can
learn that business
I think I can apply some things about
leadership that I already understand
yeah and um you know I have great people
helping me learn that business yeah you
know a really good friend of mine Deion
Taylor who
my wife introduced me to him and his
wife Roxanne and just like she's an
actress right yes and just like
different people like that that are
really helping me along this journey
um and teaching like I'm I'm very
thankful for and it's a business that I
really
really do love that's great okay final
overall question because I feel like it
just kind of puts a button on everything
that we discussed I read a really old
article that you did but you had a quote
that I thought was fascinating from your
mom you said my mom used to always tell
me it's not about beating the person in
front of you it's about beating the
person inside of you because most people
can't beat that person
do you feel that you have beaten that
person
ah
and although
um
although
you always feel like you're still
fighting that battle right like every
day
you gotta beat that person inside of you
but for the most part I have
I'm from Saginaw Michigan
there are so many basketball players
from Saginaw that were better than me
there were so many basketball players
around the world that were better to me
there aren't a ton that is cheap has
achieved more than me
and
in order to achieve that I had to
overcome so much self-doubt like forget
the amount of doubt that everyone else
had for me but the self-doubt that I had
to overcome
I beat him because look where I am like
math math who I'm super tight with his
dad has just saying Odie look at all the
fun you had and it's like when I look at
my life it's like
but look at all the fun I've had look at
all the fun I'm having to look at all
the fun I'm gonna have
I beat him
I still have more to beat yeah but I'm
there but I beat him I love that I am
not just saying this because it just
finished this was one of my favorites
you were fantastic I have said this
multiple times but you truly are like
the best supporter I appreciate it
everything that you've done you answer
all my basketball questions when I have
80 000 so I appreciate you doing this
and just for being a good human and good
friend so thanks so much for joining the
show well appreciate it thank you I
appreciate you too and and you know I am
a big fan of everything that you have
going and how you continue to expand
doing Thursday Night Football now and
just like and I think you know like
everything that you're doing in sports
is great
I look forward to to your role carrying
you outside of sports because you're
that good
at what you do like when
there was an article that came out on
you what didn't come out on you but
there was some article or rankings or
something that came up oh I feel it and
it was a listen like the backhand to
compliment that you got I can't remember
the guy's name it was like Paul or I
don't remember the guy's name but uh
such backhanded compliments but you are
incredible
and what you put into your craft
it's big things coming for you they're
already but they'll continue to get
bigger and bigger and you got a fan in
me no thank you Jay I appreciate you
thanks for joining Smith
all night with all of us you guys
no thanks so much
[Music]